[Music]
in long song news long song songs oh
that's a good name
what am i well now muses like a man your
porn name should be King ding-a-ling
wings
yo I'm making that a skit that's so dope
no look it's like King like a dingaling
means penis and in lingling is what they
call like little asian girls you know
King ding-a-ling submitted by dominating
humbly from the bay Oh Jo a criminal
defense attorney gives her opinion on
our Kelly's new 19 minute song called I
admit this is crazy I haven't heard that
I heard about it I've heard the whole
thing
but I've heard inserts of the 19 minute
song and it's why hold it he's lost his
shoe really actually sat through the
whole thing how was it was it great is
it on YouTube well the link that I had
was genius I [ __ ] love art Kelly yeah
me too he's back dude what'd you miss
about him is exactly what's bad I love
people that are so [ __ ] delusional
and so God and they have this god
complex but they have no [ __ ] idea I
love that [ __ ] dude I mean no one
condones peeing on a underage girl but I
mean it's not Kelly exactly like he's
lost his mind what do you think remember
back in the days when that was okay with
no one cared right yeah so back in the
day when he peed on underage girls it
was more viewed as this guy is crazy and
it's hilarious
you know it was more of like but you
focus more on the peeing part like
that's so funny I can't believe this
guy's peeing on people right it was a
scandal though dude it was on the news
yeah it was bad I think for us maybe it
was our mindset
no no what made it funny was Dave
Chappelle he made that song I want you
so good also look not gonna lie
okay look to be real I was bumping some
old art Kelly the other day I think it
was I was bumping like the Chocolate
Factory or TP to like just classic
albums and there was some song that came
on I was like uh cuz it makes you think
a little girl I'm gonna come
a little bit because there's one arguing
song it's like especially with the
current climate right just like how
everything's not changing there's a song
that's alright killer song it's like
don't you say no tonight and I was like
mmm cuz he's gonna pee I was like I
don't know if that's a good lyric
anymore or Kelly's been through a lot of
[ __ ] like he's saying that his name has
been dragged through the dirt I think he
dragged himself in the mud he's trying
to clear his name so this is his
comeback what was what is it called
again Africa I admit oh yes yeah so what
he's admitting here is that he did have
sex with his fans mm-hmm that that's not
just the world that's everybody if he
said I had sex with a 13 year old fan
then that's like okay we but we also
know that he did say something along the
lines of like okay so like this is one
of the worst
I admit I [ __ ] with all the ladies
that's both older and young ladies but
tell me how they call it pedophile
because that [ __ ] is crazy oh this is he
admits he's illiterate yeah he can't
read yeah yeah he's a neat - he's a
singer I know but this is all this [ __ ]
oh like something about the Emmys or the
Grammys that he when he was presenting
the he didn't know he'd the prompter he
couldn't read the prompt
oh [ __ ] you sniff that he also this is
another one so he addresses how remember
we talked about him the cult yeah oh the
cycle like the sex : how he was like
holding a girl hostage to do any much so
he says this please read this please
read the lyrics okay if you really
really want to know her father dropped
her off at my show and told this boy to
put her on stage don't push your
daughter in my face and tell me that
it's okay cuz your agenda is to get paid
and get mad when it don't go your way no
no the actual one where he's talking
about the call he's like where he's like
really like look I'm gonna do that
really bits and pieces of it I wish you
guys could yeah I want to listen to some
insert was at least 19 minutes you guys
can google it on your own
the way he sings it it's like he's
talking like trapped in the closet
trapped in the closet
zactly exactly man like cuz pardon me
right now is like [ __ ] man this is
really like this is it's it feels it's
like he's sick in the head low-key right
absolutely
but then it's like [ __ ] trapped in the
closet was so good did you watch the
whole thing
I love chaplain clubs back to back one
day I sat down I want some [ __ ] one
too like 38 it turns into a Hypnotizer
it's amazing that's how its genius I
think now they watch maybe like I'm not
even happy it's how you're watching it
so if you're watching for what it is it
sucks
yeah well you can't look at it that way
are you putting on this you gotta look
at it from the comedy level except the
comedy lens is different because okay
you gotta see it as this dude truly
[ __ ] believes this is a masterpiece
it is but not in the way he intended it
that's the death that's the difference
because he's so [ __ ] serious about it
I think that's what I love no but I
think he knows it's funny you think so
because there's literally parts where
that the lyrics are says yes he says no
I says yes I said naw sis you crazy
he knows this is entertaining and
there's one part where a [ __ ] a little
person busts out from the bottom of the
sea oh it's the best
any things in different accents and [ __ ]
ah so good he does the voices of the
ladies what it is here yeah pretty much
it's [ __ ] good man I don't know if
it's as gold as that but it's it's wild
and then he even like mentions how he
loves you Hefner and I see left this
world with a million girls and then this
one dude Jim DeRogatis or this dude has
pretty much been on our Kelly for the
past two decades like just always
writing about his accusations and like
all this [ __ ] and so he was saying he
even shouted him out to Jim do de
crotches whatever your name is whatever
your name is
you've been trying to destroy me for 25
whole years with the same stories over
and over against off my name you done
went and made yourself a career but
guess what I pray for you and and family
and all my other enemies if he's batshit
[ __ ] crazy so back in the early 2000s
when he was doing more of that Phantom
of the Opera [ __ ]
I told the story before but you never
heard it so my buddy used to do camera
work for him okay and he says one day
like during a live concert in the middle
of the [ __ ] show right he's wearing
his [ __ ] you know it's the fact the
master said hey mask escape and he has
the inspiration to stop the show in the
middle of it go across the street to
McDonald's and start serving hamburgers
what so he just [ __ ] stops and he
goes outside and then everyone's like oh
my god it's [ __ ] art Kelly right so
he goes behind the counter and he starts
giving hamburgers to the people and
people were just waiting in the audience
like where the [ __ ] did he go interest
he's like that foods like nuts dude you
just do [ __ ] like that out of nowhere
and I just wish he wasn't a pedophile
like you peed on some 18 year old girls
yeah I wish it was if he peed on 18 yo
completely different that's like who
cares yeah but it's like the fact that
she you know a 16 year old it's like nah
and y'all know he was he was supposedly
like married to Aaliyah right yeah well
she was yeah he was 24 28 wait that's
what I don't get is like okay so
yeah under 18 you're a pedophile but you
can marry some girls in some states
under 18 or for this particular
situation she lied about her age and
said she was 18 and then the parents
found out so she locked it and then
someone wrote in some book that
apparently she art Kelly thought that
she was pregnant yeah you're crazy man
so then yeah so there's this criminal
defense attorney I wonder if he's the
opposite like 15 12 much Anatomy
you're [ __ ] wait oh they're not touch
was why do you lie to me every census
comes out as no that's literally the
song dude the whole song he's like
preaching it there's criminal defense
attorneys she's listening to this entire
song and said the fact that he did say
that he done [ __ ] with a couple of
fans if a fan were to later accuse him
of sexual misconduct
he has already admitted to having sexual
combat such a general blanket statement
so why is it wrong to [ __ ] with fans
though no it's just like she's saying
like anything you say can be used
against oh I said they can universe
heart yeah that's like saying like oh
you saw that scene in the movie like
Denzel I know you were a crooked cop
that's a fair point
no music though so recently there was a
rapper that got sent to jail because the
the court used his songs as proof for
the crimes that he committed really but
I thought it was like when it's when
it's are like music you can cuz like
sometimes I've heard about [ __ ] where a
rapper like couldn't talk about things
in interviews but he could talk about
everything in a song you know I'm saying
because it's like it's arts like First
Amendment might be changing these days
yeah so because she did say that there's
an argument to be made that those lyrics
are admissible that's like that key and
peele see you guys know where it's uh
he's a rapper and he admits to all these
crimes and then he's like no I didn't do
it and they played the album and it
tells like all the details of it and
yeah I think key and Peele was making
fun of it but now it's becoming real
yeah that's [ __ ] crazy so pretty much
she was just saying like even though
she's saying a lot of her clients think
that just by saying I didn't do it we'll
help
their case but just saying anything can
hurt your case even though you're saying
you're not doing it so she was just
telling her Kelly
it's a tricky time because I know
recently Hulk Hogan went through some
[ __ ] like he got a sex tape that was
released and then this whole scandal
actually took down a website Gawker yeah
it took down that web site and during
the court argument what they're saying
is um a Hulk Hogan said some racist
things he said whatever but in court he
was like that's whole Colgan I was
that's that character that said that not
not me or like that was I don't know
what what he said but like it was like
one could get away because this person
saying it his character not him or
whatever so it's like it's like a
scripted thing yeah yeah and and they're
like it's messing up my brand and
whatever so it's like where you draw the
line of people being accountable it's
like if I say whatever I want on JK news
I'm like no no that's Joe Mallya Joe
that's that character That's not me yeah
and I should do that I should [ __ ]
rob a 7-eleven no no no no that's
[ __ ] that's not me dude that's Joe
Mallya Joe as long as you feel me
[Music]